a random shooting at a gas station the
gunman and tactical gear you heard
police sound the alarm here on this
program yesterday and now we'll be
seeing that alleged shooter in court in
about an hour it all happened near
robindale and jones in the southwest
valley yesterday morning our victoria
saha joins us now with more on the man
accused of pulling the trigger and the
victim a 35-year-old man shot to death
sitting in his car victoria
took down their crime tape it's where
curtis abraham was sitting in his car
when the suspect jesus reba shot him
this morning uribe's family didn't have
much to say
we knocked on the door where 22 year old
jesus aribe lived a man answered the
door he wouldn't tell me how he was
related to uribe did you suspect
anything
if there's there's a message to the
victim's family to the public
we're
just after midnight thursday police say
uribe walked into the parking lot of
short line express market wearing
tactical gear he then reportedly shot up
an empty car police say that's when he
walked over to curtis abraham's car and
shot him to death before going to the
store where he started shooting at
customers as they ran for their lives a
rebate then ran off and a search ensued
12 hours later after the shooting police
say a tip led them to aurora glove
street where uribe lived just minutes
from the crime scene he refused to come
out and it turned into a barricade
incident but police were able to arrest
him by thursday evening
got a chance to briefly speak with the
victim's family in maryland they say
they are completely devastated and will
be releasing a statement soon as for
uribe he is expected to appear in court
1 30 this afternoon reporting near jones
and rainbow victoria saha live local now